that is all stated to be in the interest
of us being ruled by our reason
[Music]
what is the longest surviving written
constitution in human history
the magna carta students are wonderful
those are the ten commandments are those
constitutions
i don't know it's an agreement between
god and the hebrews
is it it's worth a shot i don't think
they're the 10 contractual provisions
no the magna carta is uh
it's kind of it's an element of the
british constitution it's true
but the british constitution doesn't
come to be with that it takes more
[Music]
oh come on you guys got to be able to
answer that question the american
constitution
we have now named the elephant in the
room
this constitution is the longest
surviving thing of its kind in all of
human history
and i think we've reached why
right here step one it gives effect
to consent to representation step
two it locates all the sovereignty
in the people not in the government no
one in the government
can say that he or she is acting of
his own will right step
three it excludes the sovereign from the
ordinary operation
of the government which places a check
on the sovereign
too and that is all stated to be
in the interest of us being ruled
by our reason through discussion
james madison was aware that reason and
speech are the same thing
we should talk things through before we
do them
and it should not be our passions
passions don't tend to last that long
convictions do
reason does and you're arguing about it
all the time
all along the way and that means that
madison says that these arrangements
here this connection
between the people and the government
that gives
power to the government locates ultimate
authority in the people
prescribes how the people must must hold
opinions
over time to make them effective this a
set of arrangements
what does this make it possible for them
to do
they can delegate the authority to more
than one place
you can give the legislative power
to the congress in article one
of the constitution you can give the
executive power to the president
in article two of the constitution
they each have their own relationship
with the sovereign people they are quite
equal as regards authority
you can give all the judicial power
in article 3 to the courts
and you can use article 1 and article 2
institutions to combine to appoint the
judges
you can leave most of the power
in the hands of the state and you can
protect that
in article 4 of the constitution
you see the symmetry and the strength of
that
all made possible by this
consent and representation as the
sovereign was
in the government whatever part of the
government madison writes this over and
over in the federalist hamilton too
whatever part of the government the
sovereign was in that would become the
dominant part
whereas now we can separate the powers
and then they can be stronger which you
need
but still also safe so what that means
then
is that the principle of human equality
under the laws of nature
and of nature's god gives rise and all
this happens by the way
in about eight lines in the declaration
of independence
gives rise to the principle of
government by consent
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men are created equal and endowed by
the creator with certain unalienable
rights
among these life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just
powers from the consent of the governed
that follows from equality
up above under the authority of the
natural law
which is just our perception of what
kind of thing
each of us is right we're not like dogs
we're also interested enough not like
god or the angels
who are mentioned in the declaration of
independence
right and so once you've got that then
all of a sudden
you lay the ground for a government
that is grounded in the people but but
the powers are so arranged so that the
better angels of our nature
to quote lincoln drive the government
and that the claim by the founders
and the claim by me they believe the
founders believe that this government
because it's in accord with human nature
which is
that nature above the beast and below
god
this government can last a long time
in principle as long as the earth lasts
or people last
and it has lasted a long time
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn